it may not seem like it but teasing done
with affection and skill is a profound
human accomplishment there is a nasty
teasing of course in which we pick away
at a sore spot in someone's life but
here we're talking of the affectionate
version something generous and loving
which feels good to be on the receiving
end of it can be lovely to be teased
when for example you're a teenager and
in a grumpy sullen mood and your kindly
dad nicknames you Hamlet Shakespeare's
Danish prince of gloom or when you're 45
and pretty serious in business and your
old university friends come around and
call you by that name they made up for
you when you were aged 19 the night you
failed dismally trying to pick up a
German girl who was in town all of us
get a bit unbalanced in one way or
another too serious too gloomy too jokey
and so we all benefit from being tugged
back towards a healthier mean the good
teaser latches on to and responds to our
distinctive imbalances and gets
compassionately constructive about
trying to change us not by delivering a
stern lesson but by helping us to notice
our excesses and laugh at them we sense
the teaser trying to give us a useful
little shove in a good and secretly
welcome direction and therefore we know
that at it's affection at best teasing
is at once sweet and constructive the
English literary critic Cyril Connolly
once famously said imprisoned in every
fat man is a thin man wildly signaling
to be let out it's a general idea with
multiple variants inside the fussy /
formal individual there's a more relaxed
person looking for an opening there's an
ambitious eager self quietly despairing
within the lazy man the gloomy
disenchanted cynic harbors a more cheery
sunny sup self in need of more
recognition the teasing remark speaks
over the head of one's dominant
personality to the subordinated side of
the self whom it helps to release and
relax there's a moment in the line of
beauty
a novel by Alan hauling Hurst set in the
1980s in which Nick the charming young
central character is invited to a grand
party where he meets the British Prime
Minister Margaret Thatcher everyone is
slightly terrified of her but Nick
warmly and teasingly suggests that she
might like to dance to a pop song the
other guests are horrified she's meant
to be obsessed by stringent economic
reform and hard-nosed politics but after
a brief in a struggle she replies with a
smile you know I'd like that very much
perhaps if in reality there'd been more
people to tease her the pop loving
dancing side of mrs. Thatcher might have
played a greater role in national
affairs and history would have been
different when we enjoy being warmly
teased it's because the teasing remark
emerges from a genuine insight into who
we are this person has studied us and
put their finger on a struggle that's
going on in us they've taken the part of
a nice but currently under supported
side of who we are it's pleasing because
normally others don't see much past the
front we put on for the world typically
the world just thinks of us as gloomy or
Stern or intellectual or obsessed by
fashion the teaser does us the favor of
recognising that the dominant front
isn't telling the whole story they're
kind enough and perceptive enough to see
past the surface perhaps the most
instructive question we can ask the one
that teaches us most about the value of
affection of teaching is simply what do
I need to be teased about
you
you